welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the pretty cool
guy who kicks more ice than your average
snowflake and we have a whole host of
updates on the DC Universe the last week
is being completely packed when it comes
to Batman news and throughout this video
we're gonna be breaking down all of the
brand new details this includes news on
Michael Keaton's appearance in the flash
debunking the ben affleck returning
leaks potentially a 100 Easter eggs and
a lot more now there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't anything
potentially ruined about the upcoming DC
movies that I highly recommend that you
turn off now please smash that thumbs up
button if you've been enjoying the
coverage so far and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel to never miss
an update without the way thank you for
clicking this and let's get into our
breakdown of all the new Batman details
okay so if you've been living in a
Batcave for the past week and you might
have missed the news that the granddaddy
of the bat family Michael Keaton will be
reprising his role as Batman in the
upcoming flash movie the flashpoint
centric film will reportedly see him
take over the reigns of Ben Affleck and
he will act as a mentor for the DC
characters across the universe including
flash Batgirl and many more the story
broke the internet better than bein
broke the bat and it's had fans
extremely excited we now have some
further news in regards to the film
including what the bat suit will be and
a lot more now The Hollywood Reporter
recently did a massive post about all
their scoops and updates from insiders
that contained the following information
Michael Keaton is in talks to return his
Batman and by Batman we also mean Bruce
Wayne despite pesky rumors from certain
corners there's no Thomas Wayne in the
script sources tell us also Keaton would
appear in costume so pretty short and
sweet but it does let us know two major
things though the flash movie will be a
flashpoint one there will be absolutely
no Thomas Wayne in the film this is a
pretty big bummer
if it turns out to be true as I was
really excited to see Jeffrey Dean
Morgan reprise the role of the character
and I think that he would look absolute
incredible in the costume the Thomas
Wayne Batman version in my opinion is
one of the most interesting depictions
of the dog night and it kind of seems a
shame that they aren't using him as he's
really integral to the graphic novel and
makes for a great character
I'm guessing this means we won't be
getting a Martha Wayne Joker either he
was a big shame as she adds a lot of
intriguing aspects of the source
material and it was such a big twist the
first time I read the graphic novel it
just feels like a massive miss here so
lots of bad news but with this bad news
also comes the good news that Michael
Keaton will be appearing in costume the
rumor is that like the original book
after flash fixes things he returns to
the Batcave to see what the status quo
is the Batcave was a key location in the
alternate version of history as when he
went there and found Thomas instead of
Bruce he knew that things were wrong so
flash altering the past once more
ventures back to the Batcave to see if
he's living in a universe with either
Thomas a Bruce and according to the
leaks he finds a much older version of
Wayne namely Michael Keaton this is
likely how it will appear in the movie
and sources close to the Hollywood
Reporter have said that Keaton will be
appearing in the Batsuit now DC EU
mythic recently posted a report that
said Keaton will be appearing in a
version of the suit that is similar to
the Kingdom Come one this was posted by
Jeremy Conrad who has been right on a
lot of leaks but also gotten some wrong
so take this with a pinch of salt until
we know everything now in Kingdom Come
we follow much older versions of the
heroes as they come out of retirement to
save the world
Bruce spends most of his time with a
neck brace on he due to the impact that
being Batman has had on him however at
the end he returns with an armored suit
that allows him to still duke it out
with the bad guys and know he can't turn
his head but this is some brilliant
fanservice if it's the case and it
massively fits in with the aesthetic of
an older Batman petition Lee I would
hope that they go more with The Dark
Knight Returns version of the character
rather than the broken neck one as he's
pretty much in able to do a lot of
things I do think that Pattinson will
still provide us with a younger version
of Batman that can
take all kinds of ice but I would have
loved to see the older one doing it too
however The Hollywood Reporter did say
that Keaton would be more of a mentor
figure akin to Nick Fury rather than a
guy that goes out and punches people in
the face every night now as always just
like how Hugh Jackman has been rumored
to appear in every Marvel movie since
the x-men franchise got pasta Disney
News has been circulating that Ben
Affleck will be back too so firstly
Affleck has said numerous times he
doesn't want to do the role the guy has
pretty much told us the bat is dead
bury it also you don't look for other
actors such as Pattinson and Keaton if
you're thinking of still having him
around
secondly the Keaton report came from
numerous large outlets such as The Wrap
Hollywood Reporter comic book com Vanity
Fair definition decor a UK heavy
spoilers calm and all the best in the
business except for those first four
with this came the news that Thomas
Wayne was also out of the project but
absolutely nowhere mentioned that athlet
was coming back in fact they said quite
the opposite and stated that Keaton was
taking over his role and his time in the
cowl was over so from that I would say
it's pretty clear from there not being a
mention of his name alongside Keaton
that he won't be returning telling
people Affleck is back would be just as
big a story as Keaton would and thus if
his name isn't mentioned alongside the
Thomas Wayne and Keaton casting news
then we can read between the lines that
he won't be returning that being said
this is DC so you never quite know what
will happen still oh it's down to
whether Affleck would do it and he said
time and time again
no we just kind of need a let the guy
rest of it and for a role that almost
ruined his life do kind of feel it's
selfish that fans keep wanting to wheel
and back out so it can do it all over
again when there's a lot more that are
interested in doing it and would
probably love to have a chance at it
that's just my thoughts on it but as of
now until a big trade report on Affleck
being in the role I'm just gonna take it
as being untrue now before we get into
the rest of the video I just wanna let
you know we're giving away a free copy
of the MCU infinity saga box set to one
random
subscriber all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the news in the
comments section below who when it's
going to be chosen at random on the 15th
of July and the set will be shipped out
from them to ever gets the prize it's
the best of luck to everyone who takes
part okay and lastly we have two bits of
news in regards to the Matt Reeves
Batman movie firstly in an interview
with Robert Pattinson which talks about
what it's like to embody Batman let's
check it out every single time I say one
sentence about that man this massive and
offending Suede's of that bad fans that
I mean it's kind of I mean the
interesting thing about Batman itself is
that you could base it it's been played
in so many different ways the the comics
covers so much ground the movies cover
so much ground I mean if you're going on
there kind of if you're trying to play a
historically accurate Batman I mean you
could literally play anything so I guess
it's kind of what Matt Reeves is
directing it kind of wants to go for and
I have always find it until you are on
set and it's until you can feel what it
feels like to be around the other actors
to be in the costume I mean that the few
times I've been in that's not even the
real costume yet they were not just
doing the screen test and stuff I mean
it's pretty astonishing how different
you feel when when you put it on you can
have as many ideas as you want and as
soon as you put that costume on it feels
you know an entirely different situation
when she could never have predicted it
makes you a lot larger and people also
that I think the main thing as well as
something we're covering your face it
like going around with a mask on to
anybody I mean it it it does something
to everyone around it you know they know
you know they know who it is underneath
but it's just I could even I could feel
even than a few few minutes I was doing
it people kind of behave differently
around you and and you would just never
you'd never really know
okay so kind of handing out what it's
like to take on the role and I like that
he's talking about this additional
persona that being Batman gives you
throughout all the comics I've read on
the character I've always felt that
Bruce Wayne is the mask and Batman is
the true face so I absolutely love this
idea of what's going on with its
thinking behind the character this seem
like this variation of Batman is gonna
be unlike anything we've seen before and
this has been given further way by a new
crew announcement now firstly shouts the
bat source for spotting this on IMDB we
can't see that Chris lines has been
added to the behind the scenes crew is
someone doing this special effects teeth
a lot of people think that this has
something to do with the penguin Killer
Croc or Firefly but I actually have a
completely different theory in the
graphic novel Batman yay 100 which you
should definitely pick up Batman
actually wears false teeth in it in this
storyline in order to appear more
frightening and intimidating to his foes
The Dark Knight done some fake vampire
teeth as this gives criminals in the
city the idea that he's a creature of
the night I would love to see this sort
of thing brought across and as we know
from our exclusive leaks the movie is
pulling from a lot of different aspects
in the caped crusaders rich history
Batman to rides around on a bike in that
similar to what we've seen him doing in
the behind the scenes stuff in this
movie so yeah fingers crossed I'm right
but if not I'll just delete this video
and pretend it never happened so yeah
make sure make sure you watch this a
hundred times well as well as you still
can now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on these updates and if you're
excited to see what's next
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please drop a
thumbs up as it massively helps us out
and if you missed our video last week
then now's the time to check it out we
break down the Snyder trailer talk more
about Keaton's Batman as well as Selina
Kyle's catsuit in the Matt Reeves movie
so whatever you want to know we got you
covered
but we aren't we got this covered yes
we're not we're not that bad now if you
want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below you
massively appreciate you and there's a
thank you you get access to content
early we're gonna come chat to us after
the show either follow us at heavy
spoilers or click this
link in the description below those are
the best ways to keep a debate with the
channel and hopefully we see over there
soon but if not have a lovely week and
take care of yourself
much love
[Music]
[Music]
you